الوضع الأجنبي ، إنه أمر محزن للغاية ، أعتقد أنها
مأساة ،
نعم غالبًا ما تكون فورية لأكون صادقًا ، لماذا
تعرض حياتك للخطر ، هل
حصلت على هذا القدر من المال في
شيء غبي جدًا لا يحتوي على تقنية فيه ،
يجب أن يكون الجميع قد سمعوا عن تيتانيك
شيئًا ما أنت جاد ، شيء ما هو على
وجه الخصوص إلى حد ما
يمكننا فهمه ولكن الأمر
خطير للغاية وأعتقد أنه من المحزن جدًا
إخبار الناس أنه لدينا اليوم ،
وكان ينبغي عليهم العثور على هؤلاء الأشخاص
[موسيقى]
أجانب ،
أعتقد أنها  مأساة مثل أي مأساة
ولكن أعتقد أنه تم تسليط الضوء عليها
لأنه في الأساس كانت هناك
مجموعة معينة من الأشخاص الذين اختاروا الذهاب في تلك
الرحلة وربما تحظى
باهتمام إعلامي أكبر قليلاً من
الكوارث المعتادة التي تحدث هناك في
المدينة التي  ما أعتقد أنه ربما
لأن الأشخاص المشهورين بشكل عام
والأشخاص المرتفعين هناك يحظون
باهتمام أكثر من الأشخاص العاديين ، إنه
وضع محزن في كل مكان
يأخذ خمسة متاجر أخرى وهو حطام
لا يجب أن نذهب إلى هذا الحطام ما لم
يكن لديك كل شيء تجاه المنشأة  في الثنية للعودة